Chào các quy định của bán thường vụ thành quyền, ông Trần Thánh Ha và Mítui thành quyền
Tránh văn phòng thành quyền, được nhiều đồng đến công tác tại cơ quan văn phòng đòn đại
biểu của hội và hội đồng giần thành phố giữ trước vụ chẳng văn phòng đòn đại biểu của hội và hội đồng giần thành phố.
Lông thời bán thường vụ thành quy, tiếp nhận thường tưởng quyến thành lắm, một bây tuổi, quy định bán thường vụ đồng quy,
bò giám đốc công ăn thành phố Hàn Nội, được Việt phái đến công tác tại văn phòng thành quy, giữ trước chẳng văn phòng thành quy,
pháp biểu tại bòi lẽ, mí thương thành quy hàn Nội, với giữ ngọt nếu gió,
việc bán thường vụ thành quy, quy định điều đặc bộ giệm các đồng chiếc hông này,
sất phát từ yêu cầu công tác của lạnh đạo thành phố,
đồng thời thể hiện sự tiên tưởng, đánh giá cao, đối với năng lực phẩm chất,
quá trình công tác, lực lòng góc của hai đồng chi, trong thời gian qua.